lookouts
armed with bows and arrows this is a
medieval siege in an ultra-modern system
at the entry point
everyone has searched this student is 19
years old and studying accountancy he's
our guide to the fortress
he's got lucky Castle you have a center
and then yeah this is the front line
yeah and this the second one they're
getting more serious the students have
occupied Polytechnic University for
three days now but only yesterday did
they begin at 4 to 5 they aim to keep it
you saw see you up doing this and this
Prairie University yeah because we saw
see you just done the whole barricade
are so good protesters are adapting
their tactics and learning from each
other's example kind of control majora I
would say not this tragic set because we
know we have no leaders all Australia we
the group all that people try to discuss
this is the nerve center of a
self-organizing swarm intelligence where
battle plans are drawn up along with
enough supplies to last a siege just to
give you an idea of the level of
organization this used to be a food
kiosk and now it's been turned into a
command station basically you've got
phone charges here you've got maps up
there you've got video live streams of
other protests around Hong Kong you've
got a food menu in case you want to get
a bite to eat this whole area here is a
hive of activity
the kids have taken over the school but
these kids carry petrol bombs it's not
just the university they control they've
shut down this cross Harbor tunnel a
major route diggin in on this scale is a
new tactic an escalation but the goal is
still the same
to preserve Hong Kong's traditional
freedoms from mainland China the Hong
Kong government says it will not
negotiate with violent protesters and as
chief executive Kara Lam has branded
them enemies of the people as night fell
the police still stayed away a chance to
test more homemade weapons they mean
serious damage and there is a paranoia
here about spies that could quickly turn
ugly in the meantime some rest while
others keep watch waiting for the battle
that they are sure will come tom
Cheshire's going to use alcohol